they took a risk I'm gonna put my money
in an uninsured bank because I'm getting
back all this like you know and
sometimes I think it was like they did
this with their businesses and then they
get the personal mortgages which is also
it's just a kickback so I say we don't
bail those people out because we have
the rules and these are the rules now a
lot of these people are big names they
have the ability to go on to every show
that exists on TV and whatnot and claim
that this is going to be a systemic risk
but I don't believe that frankly
um
and so you know I I think what we need
to do and nobody's talking about it is
put the regulations back we have now
proved that it's dangerous
um uh to have rolled back the
regulations on these mid-sized Banks and
so uh you know the the deafening Silence
about it is amazing to me
foreign
[Music]